almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice comm slash
Pakman to download it
we have newly released audio of Donald
Trump and the audio exposes Donald Trump
I guess pretending during a call with
governors that he hadn't heard about
coronavirus testing being a problem now
you know and I know that lack of testing
has been a problem for months now it's
been a topic at almost every single
White House coronavirus press briefing
but Trump is I guess gaslighting
governor's saying testing people can't
get tests I haven't heard anything about
that lately so this call took place
Monday this was with governor's from a
number of the different states and
Montana governor Democratic governor in
a red state Steve Bullock explained we
don't have tests and Trump says I
haven't heard about that issue
testing testing is a problem so let's go
to the first clip you're going to hear
dr. Anthony foutch II in the audio and
you'll hear governor steve bullock and
then you're going to hear Trump so first
foul she is explaining to Bullock what
you want to do is you want to test
people and then contact trace people and
Bullock says contact tracing we don't
even have we're almost out of tests here
take a listen do you have can adequately
identify cases and isolate them and
contact trace them what are the
capabilities in resources there that
that's not something that you can do
given with what you have yeah don't
decide we are trying to do contact rate
but literally we are one day away we
don't get just tips from the CDC then we
would be able
in Montana we have gone time and time
again to the private side of this the
private market and where the private
market is telling us is that it's the
national resources that are then taking
our order to part mark basically we're
getting our orders canceled that's what
people eat at for testing supplies
that's for testing equipment so while
we're trying to do all the contact
tracing we don't have adequate tests to
necessarily do we don't have the PCP
along the way and we're not finding the
market to be able to do that so
understand dr. pouchy is saying you know
what would be but what you would want to
be doing is when people test positive
you've got to isolate them and then
you've got to do contact tracing in
Montana figure out who they've been in
touch with and isolate those people this
is how South Korea did it they had their
first case essentially within hours of
the United States having its first
confirmed case and they dealt with the
virus successfully still not not even
200 deaths total in South Korea and
governor Steve Bullock says contact
tracing
we're like a day or two from having no
tests at all and having no PPE left
personal protective equipment so now we
continue with the same audio and you'll
hear Donald Trump jump in and say I
haven't heard about testing being a
problem along the way of private
suppliers though we do have to rely on a
national chain of distribution of work
we're not going to get it but we are
doing our best to try to do exactly that
in like this gallon County would be an
example where we have almost half our
overall states those are the Protestants
so we're trying to shift the supply -
really - laid back and do the contact
training but we just don't have enough
supply to either do the dusting I tell
me you can answer it if you want but I
haven't heard about testing in weeks
we've tested more now the elimination in
the world we've got these great tests
and we come up with another one tomorrow
words and you know it's almost
instantaneous testing but I haven't
heard of that testing being a problem
that version of Trump that we see at the
briefings where he says hey we're
testing more than anybody else we've got
the best tests that is apparently not a
character that appears to be the real
Donald Trump that shows up to the
governor's conf
calls as well and says testing I don't
know about any problem with testing we
have people waiting eight days for test
results and anecdotally we have people
waiting even longer if and when they can
get a test which not everybody can there
are hundreds of people thousands of
people who are recovering from the virus
before they even get their test results
if you can believe it because that's how
long it's taking do you guys think that
Trump is even thinking about this stuff
between press briefings like I like to
imagine excuse me that a president is
working all day on this despite having
you know an almost totally clear
schedule which Donald Trump has had but
then he comes out with this testing I
haven't heard about any kind of testing
issues for weeks and you have to wonder
is he just doing golf simulator and
eating his famous taco salads all day
and not thinking about this whatsoever
he even talked about testing this week
he was asked about testing this week by
reporters that led to the entire per
capita you know 38 million people live
in Seoul South Korea embarrassment how
can he say he hasn't heard anything
about testing for weeks a reporter asked
them about it the same day or the day
before that this conference call took
place so the question as often as the
question with Donald Trump is he merely
ignorant is he impaired and his memory
is failing him is he just lying to
governor's and gaslighting them what do
you think is going on here what do you
believe explains Trump saying I haven't
heard anything about testing for weeks
now